yo grito de apoyo profundo buenos aires
niños salieron a las calles de la
capital argentina para defender a su
vicepresidenta cristina fernández tras
ser acusada de corrupción durante su
presidencia sus partidarios se reunieron
el sábado frente a su casa pero la
provocación de hoy a la madrugada de
poner las vallas es un símbolo que no
queríamos permitir que suceda que es
mientras la justicia quiere encarcelar a
cristina fernández de kirchner la red a
lo que hizo es encarcelar su casa las
marchas se tornaron violentas por
enfrentamientos entre la policía y los
manifestantes
fernández agradeció a sus seguidores y
condenó lo que catalogó de la prisión
cristiana
[Aplausos]
para que sigan amenazando
contigo
carla que logra pimienta y decirles que
gracias y pedirles bueno que vayamos a
descansar un poco que ha sido un largo
día el presidente alberto fernández
también se presionó a culminar la
violencia
expresó mi más enérgico repudio a la
violencia institucional desatada por el
gobierno de la ciudad frente a una
masiva manifestación de ciudadanas y
ciudadanos expresándose en libertad y en
democracia la fiscalía del país pidió 12
años de prisión para la vicepresidenta y
su inhabilitación vital 11 a las
supuestas irregularidades en la
adjudicación de obras públicas durante
su mandato
fernández estaba siendo investigada por
presunta corrupción en la concesión de
51 obras públicas a un empresario afín
en la región de santa cruz en el sur del
territorio argentino pero el veredicto
final todavía debe esperar se prevé que
llegue a finales de año y fernández
podrá apelar la decisión
además tiene inmunidad política hasta
2023 por ser presidenta del senado y
vice presidenta argentina